Un polaco se llamaba Piłsudski, con picotes grandes.
Un hombre poderoso, un hombre no ladrón, un hombre levradero, polaco y diarista.
Cada uno que tenía tres hectáreos tierra, el quitó de grandes haciendados y cada uno
dieron tres hectáreos bosque.
Ya yo no fui más para mi suegro, los meses corren rápido y yo empecé a comprar árboles
ya de polacos.
Ya sabían que yo compro y así empezó creciendo muy rápido.
¿Y le respetaban a usted?
Más que nada respeto, quiero.
Nadie no puede creer que es el muchacho que está haciendo.
Los años corren, ya está llegando diez años, once años y yo estoy creciendo.
Mi suegro, como yo explico a usted, tenía tres hijos, yo conocí a ella cuando estaban
imprimidos, así como muchachitos y siempre la verdad es que me gustó a ella y se quedó
como dice Talmud, que significa dos palabras, se quedó agravada y a mí me mola, la muchachita.
Usted sabe que la juventud es muy linda y muy dura.
Y yo pasé mi negocio cada día más, cada día más, cada día más, creciendo, creciendo,
creciendo muy alto.
Llegó situación en el mundo, 1929, que fue una crisis mundial.
Seguro que usted sabe la historia.
Esto que yo digo a usted, con este señor, que mi mamá empeñó en la caverna, rápido
pagó, tomó con mi mamá sus regalos de su querida esposa, y más grandes comerciantes
se mataron.
Se tumbaron de pisos muy altos.
Ese sabe todo el mundo que pasó en el año 29, 33.
Y ya usted tenía bar mitzvah.
Yo y mi ciudad.
No hice bar mitzvah con 12 años.
Usted levantase, que era una bélgica, no tiene padre, con padre es 13 años y bélgica
con 12 años.
Mi bar mitzvah, no quiero mucho hablar, era muy pobre.
No era kiddush, era una cosa que no era minyan, usted me entiende.
Era una cosa, como yo puedo a usted decir, es inexplicable.
Usted sabe que es Misharia, que fue todo destruido, dos años, y ahí estaba, no faltaba
dinero.
No era, mire, como hacer una fiesta, como entrar aquí, mire, un asfa, donde una fiesta.
Todo estaba destruido, mire.
La fiesta fue construida un poquito más tarde, en Ladava.
Todo lo que estoy explicando era hecho un poquito más tarde.
Yo en ese tiempo no tenía nada de dinero.
Compró de contado y vendió de contado.
¿En qué tiempo?
29, 30, 31.
¿Cuántos años yo tenía?
Nació el 12 y el 31.
¿Cuántos años hay?
De 12 a 31, 18 años, ¿no?
19 años.
De 19 años ya era un señor.
Entonces, ya repensaron, ya construyó muy linda casa, mis hermanas ayudaron, y trabajaron
conmigo, no eran socios míos, no trabajaron conmigo, y yo pagaba.
Así, cogiendo los años, cogiendo los años.
Mi negocio después se llamaba, era, quiero te explicar.
Cuando yo compraba los bosques, los árboles de polacos, era servitud, servitud.
Ellos conseguían, ¿cuántos hectáreas?
Muchos.
Mi negocio, en el año 34, se llamaba esclavoada.
Tenía tablas para la venta, ya tenía muchas cosas.
Ya vinieron polacos que necesitan, mire, una casa.
Ya tenía obreros que trabajaban, prepararon.
Y Néstor ya era especialista.
Una pregunta.
¿En Boldava la comunidad judía era muy grande?
¿Había muchos judíos y no judíos?
Desde Spolakia era muy poco.
Llegaron de todos los pueblos, de todas las ciudades, y creciendo, como vamos a decir,
cuando llegó a Venezuela, por ejemplo, en el año 46,
Valencia tenía 60.000 habitantes.
Hoy tiene 2.000 habitantes.
Caracas tenía 160.000 habitantes.
Hoy tiene casas, 5.000 habitantes.
Allá fue creciendo muy rápido.
Volvieron dos o tres ciudades.
Se pusieron, como dijo usted, pequeños negocios de madera.
La mayoría eran negocios de madera.
Eran también negocios que vendieron.
La situación era cada día mejorando.
¿Y la relación entre los judíos y los no judíos?
Era perfecta.
Eran muy unidos.
Muy unidos.
Muy unidos, muy lindos.
Él ya pasó la vida diferente, como de una guerra, ¿sabe?
Y creciendo, la economía creciendo.
Usted sabe que los polacos son grandes trabajadores.
Allá, cuando un polaco tenía dos hectáreas de tierra,
allá, por ejemplo, en octubre ya hay frío.
Octubre, noviembre, diciembre, enero, febrero, marzo, muy frío.
Ya cada uno tenía papas para seis meses comer,
cochino, queso, mantequilla, huevos preparados para seis meses.
Tenía preparado.
Seis meses, pero cuidaban que tenía vacas, caballos, y criando gallinas.
¿Cómo eran las fiestas en su casa, las fiestas judías?
¿Cómo las celebraban?
¿Cómo yo quiero usted decir una cosa?
Mi mamá no se casó más.
Me estaban cinco hermanos.
Yo era un muchacho, para mí no era día, no era noche.
Te digo la verdad.
Los Shabbat,
era Shabbat, por la ley, como tiene que ser.
¿Cuántos me vinieron de Miñán para casa?
Aquí, también hay religiosos.
No hay esta atmósfera que existía en ese tiempo.
Por la ley, cuando viernes, se abre la puerta y se entra a la casa.